un raymond tu connais civile de plus de
vingt ans quelle est la différence entre
la luna de 2001 et le hana de 2021 de
l'oseille le pouvoir d'achat
[Rires]
vraiment il n'ya pas il ya vraiment
c'est vrai ya pas il n'y a pas beaucoup
de changements il ya vraiment pas
beaucoup de changements je trouve qu'il
ya un truc qui a changé chez toi c'est
que tu es plus rapide maintenant tu vois
des choses plus rapidement they put
épaté plus patient comme avant exact
était chiant et avant mais maintenant tu
encore un peu près certain temps mais tu
veux les choses plus rapidement malgré
les ladi sa sirène il veut s'attirer
universal syrie veut ça mais ça c'est
quand tu voles battu quand tu es dans le
turf lui ont dit quand tu es dans le
futur tu veux les choses tout de suite
c'est le seul truc qui a changé
c'était bien de cyril qui dormait dans
sa voiture cyril ans marthe c'était pas
mal s aujourd'hui c'est en hélico ses
pulsions donnant
[Rires]
l'inter n'a pas changé les idées n'ont
pas changé mais ça c'est important mais
mais je vous dirais non c'est mon ami